we look at randy.next
numbers from last year he had a really
nice
uh opener for him opening start of the
year for him down in chicago
and he'll be tasked with holding down
the cleveland indians best he can and
hernandez steps in the box
as he kicks fires and the pitch is swung
on a ground ball back
up the middle and by the diving second
baseman arise into right center
so a sharply hit ground ball results in
a
cesar hernandez single to right center
well mike clevenger will be a nissan
starting pitcher for the indians tonight
and gleb coming off a good start against
kansas city where he allowed two runs
went seven innings had six strikeouts
and last year against the minnesota
twins he was uh two and one
in his four games with the 239 earned
run average
well mike clevenger will try to make it
eight consecutive incredible starts by
this indians rotation
kepler has 14 career homers off indians
pitching
a drive right center field hit very
deep and gone into the second deck
and kepler who has two three home run
games against the indians
continues to torment terry francona he's
missing by a lot here in this first
inning and so he's given up a homer
a single a walk he has one strikeout
one down twins at first and second
and eddie rosario and the pitch is
swinging a fly ball
right center field deep in the gap that
ball traveling near the wall it's in
play one ops off the wall
donaldson will score cruz around third
he is heading home
the throw will be late it's cut off at
the mound
it's a two-run double for rosario and
what a start three-nothing twins here in
the opening inning alex avila
first year in minneapolis taylor sets up
inside in the 1-1 a swing at a fly ball
right field and deep back it goes deep
it goes and go on
number one for avila as the twin a home
run out to right
it's a four-nothing twins lead very nice
short compact swing
club tries to come inside here
he throws his hands once you throw his
hands in close to his body so that he
can get some extension with the big end
of the bat
josh donaldson's out of the game they
ray adrianza
is in oh and now they're just telling us
that it's
right half tightness for donaldson and
that
is a recurring injury for donaldson
jose ramirez lined out to first his
first time up
switch hitter batting left handed twins
by four
and the yo one line drive right side a
leaping catch again by gonzalez so jose
has found the twins
first baseman twice and that time marwin
going up as high as he possibly could go
and save the run maybe two with a
leaping catch for clevenger
that's his third walk and we're only in
the fourth inning
here's luisa rise the pitch to him swung
on chopped to the second baseman
hernandez
to the back for one lindor to first
double play good dig by santana
two down base is empty on the twin
killing he did a 3-6
that's why i knew they were going to
turn that double play he did the hokey
pokey
look at that i've never seen that
ramirez is at second base now with
nobody out in the sixth drive down four
zip
now the set now the pitch it's swung on
and grounded sharply to first
on his knees backhanded stopped by
gonzalez flips to clifford covering to
get
lindor ramirez to second good play by
gonzales going towards second with kind
of that
half knee slide stop
ramirez still at third with two down
swing
a little topper by the mound near second
and it gets between polanco on a rise
and into center field
and the indians get a gift run ramirez
scores
and reyes hustles to second with that
ball trickling into shallow center and
arise and polanco
looking at each other not going out and
getting the ball
and then reyes hustle to second and the
indians now
trail four to one tribe down four to one
here in the eighth
ramirez at second with two down full
count
eighth inning 3-2 pitch he got him
strike three called on the outside
corner
no fans no matter rubble all sorts of
pumped up crossing the first base line
as he strikes out two in a scoreless
heathen
ninth inning and taylor rogers
will try to close it out for minnesota
so far he's only pitched in one game but
he did
pick up a save two down and now domingo
santana
he delivers and it's swung on another
weak bouncer
too short polanco with a hat trick
throws out
santana the indians ground out to short
in all three advance here in the ninth
inning and taylor rogers and the twins
get the dominant pitching here tonight
and they've even this series
at a game of peace as minnesota takes
care of the tribe by a final score
of four to one